welcome to the history and evolution of
AWS section where we're going to have an
overview of AWS a description of what
it's used for and we'll also take a look
at the history and evolution of AWS so
what is AWS well I'm pretty sure you all
have a good idea otherwise you wouldn't
have signed up for this course in the
first place but Amazon Web Services is a
secure cloud services platform and what
that means is that it offers cloud-based
infrastructure for compute database
storage content delivery and other
functionality to help businesses grow
and scale now you don't have to be
all-in on the cloud you can run hybrid
applications across your existing
on-premises and cloud services using AWS
it offers pay-as-you-go pricing and this
is the biggest difference between
existing IT infrastructure and cloud
services so you only pay for the time
that you are actually using AWS
resources the vast array of AWS products
and services allows you to build
sophisticated applications that have
increased flexibility scalability and
reliability that you could only dream of
with your existing on-site
infrastructure also security in the
cloud is recognized as being better than
on-premise due to AWS being able to use
its size and experience to provide
security certification and accreditation
many data encryption capabilities and
exceptional hardware security and also
AWS is truly global it's available in a
hundred and ninety countries through 12
different geographic regions so let's
take a look at the timeline of AWS was
back in late 2003 when Chris Pinkham and
Benjamin Black first presented a paper
describing a vision for Amazon's retail
computing infrastructure
it was completely standardized and
completely automated and would rely
extensively on web services near the end
of their presentation they mentioned a
possibility of selling virtual servers
as a service and that meant AWS was born
and it was in 2004 when simple queue
service was launched and this was Amazon
Web Services first
then in 2006 Amazon Web Services as we
know it was launched providing online
services for websites and client-side
applications by 2007 and was in claimed
that more than a hundred and eighty
thousand developers had already signed
up to use Amazon Web Services and in
2010 it was reported that all of
amazon.com retail web services had been
moved onto AWS in 2012 Amazon hosted his
first customer event in Las Vegas called
reinvent and this has been happening
ever since in 2013
AWS launched its certification program
for computer engineers with expertise in
cloud computing and in 2015 AWS started
become profitable and in q3 2015 his
revenue was 2.1 billion dollars making
it by far and away the largest cloud
provider service out there now AWS is
truly global the AWS cloud is available
in 190 countries in 12 different
geographic regions and 33 availability
zones and the AWS cloud is always
growing there's going to be five new
regions brought online in 2016 in Ohio
the US Montreal in Canada the United
Kingdom India and also in China but what
is a geographic region and what is an
availability zone well the region is a
collection of data centers that are
completely isolated from the other
Amazon regions and they do this to
achieve the greatest possible fault
tolerance and stability an availability
zone is located within a region in
isolation but is connected to other
availability zones through low latency
links so here's a diagram of Amazon Web
Services regions and availability zones
and you can see that in each region
there are multiple availability zones in
fact there's always a minimum of two in
each region and that's so that you have
fault tolerance so if there is an issue
with one of the availability zones you
can failover to the other one
now edge locations are located in most
of the major cities around the world and
the use to distribute content to
end-users would reduce latency now they
used for content delivery network and
adventure location is basically an
endpoint for Amazon CloudFront now as
you can see on the map it's more than 50
edge locations based around the world
for what are they used for well if you
were living in Sydney and hosting a
website and you had uses in London
accessing your website they're going to
get some high latency when they click on
your website to get the latest
information so you can use edge
locations to push your website data
around the world so user in London only
has to connect to the edge location
closest to it which is in London so the
latency is going to be much lower
what sets AWS apart from the competition
is the number of products it offers it
offers a broad set of global compute
storage database analytics application
and deployment services that help
organisations move faster lower their IT
costs and scale their applications and
here you can see the Amazon Web Services
console and the list of all the existing
products available and as you can see
pretty comprehensive and we're going to
look at all of these in detail in a
future section AWS is the undisputed
market leader in cloud infrastructure as
a service every year Gartner releases
something called the Magic Quadrant
which rates cloud service providers on
their ability to execute and their
completeness of vision now if you look
at the Magic Quadrant you can see that
Amazon is by far and away the leader in
this space now Amazon's Cloud is
reported to be 10 times bigger than its
next 14 competitors combined which is
pretty staggering so if you look at all
the blue dots on this graph if you take
all of them times it by 10 that's how
big Amazon is an Amazon became so big
and so dominant in this market because
it's constantly releasing new features
and innovating in fact in 2015 alone it
released 7
hundred new features
welcome to the overview of AWS products
and services section where we're going
to perform a high-level overview of all
of the products and services that are
available on Amazon Web Services so they
start with a compute section
first up is Amazon's biggest product ec2
Elastic Compute cloud which provides
resizable compute capacity in the cloud
and is intended to make web scale
computing easier for developers users
maintain complete control of their
computing resources and Amazon operates
under a pay-as-you-go model so you're
only paying for the time you're actually
using your resources it also only takes
minutes to launch new server instances
so it allows you to scale as you're
computing requirements change and we'll
have a whole lesson on ec2 as it comes
up in the exam a lot next up is the ec2
container service now this doesn't come
out much or even at all in the solutions
architect associate exam you just need
to know what it is and the ec2 container
service is a highly scalable
high-performance container management
service that supports docker containers
and allows you to easily run
applications on a managed cluster of ec2
instances so if you do see any questions
about ec2 container service
it'll probably be related to the fact
that it runs docker so if you remember
docker and ec2 contain a service that
will do for now
elastic Beanstalk is an easy-to-use
service for deploying and scaling web
applications so any web applications
developed with Java or.net or PHP etc
you can run it on the Patchi nginx
passenger and AI is all you do is upload
your code AWS inspects it and provisions
the resources for it to run this is
currently only in the exam at a high
level but you just need to know elastic
Beanstalk is for web applications
then there's lambda again this is
something that doesn't really come up in
the exam but it will do for sure in the
future so lambda lets you run your code
without provisioning or managing servers
and you pay just for the execution time
that your code is running so you can run
little self-contained snippets of
JavaScript Java or Python code to do
discrete tasks so as I said this doesn't
come up in exam much but it will do as
this really is the future of cloud
computing and finally in this section
elastic load balancing this is a
networking service
that automatically spreads our incoming
application traffic across several
available ec2 instances the service can
also detect unhealthy instances and
reroute traffic the healthy ones and
we'll do a demo with load balancing
later on so let's take a look at storage
and content delivery which is a huge
area in Amazon's products and services
and we'll start with Amazon s3 simple
storage service this is an object based
online storage service that offers a
practically unlimited data storage space
in the cloud so it's essentially a place
to store your files you can store images
and other assets for websites you can
keep backups and you can share files
between services also many other AWS
services write and read from s3 and we
cover this in a lot more detail in
another lesson and this Amazon Cloud
Front and we touched on this earlier
this is a content delivery service or a
CDN that integrates with other Amazon
cloud services to provide an easy way
for businesses and developers to
distribute data through high-speed
transfers basically you can make your
website's load much faster by spreading
out static file delivery to be closer to
where your users are using Amazon's
global network of edge locations next is
a new service from Amazon called EFS
this is basically an as in the cloud and
is storage that can be attached to
multiple ec2 instances and unlike s3 EFS
is block level storage it's been rolled
out to different regions this year so it
doesn't feature too much on the exams at
the moment but it will do next is Glacia
this is a long-term backup an archiving
service in the cloud so you can make
backups of your backups that you keep on
s3
now Glacia is extremely cheap the cost
per gigabyte is very very low the
trade-off is that you don't get instant
access to your files on Glacia it can
take several hours to get anything back
so it shouldn't be used for anything
that you need immediate access to but
for archiving historical data or both
database backups is perfect
AWS import/export no ball now this is
part of the import/export service which
is used to move large amounts of data
quickly without having to do it over the
network so if you're a company that's
looking to move all your data to Amazon
historically you would have to upload
over the Internet
now if you're talking about terabytes or
petabytes this is gonna take a long long
time so Amazon developed their
import/export service so you could send
in your external hard drives with the
data run and they would upload it into
the Amazon Cloud and snowball is an
extension of this it's an 80 petabyte
external device that you upload all your
data into and then ship it off to Amazon
and so you can get petabytes of data
into the cloud much much quicker than
before and finally in this section
storage gateway so this is a way of
extending your existing on-premise
storage into the cloud so you can set up
a virtual machine in your data center
and install storage gateway on that and
it replicates data to and from your site
to AWS so it's a cheap way of expanding
your storage now we're going to take a
look at databases another big area in
Amazon and we'll start with Amazon RDS
which is the relational database service
and RDS provides scalable relational
databases in the cloud database
administrative tasks are managed for you
by Amazon and it can even automatically
patch database software on your behalf
so this is perfect if you have an
application that just has a database and
you don't need any of the high level
database functionality you can just
launch an Amazon RDS instance connect
your application to the database and you
don't have to worry about it anymore
backups and maintenance is taken care of
on your behalf Amazon DMS is database
migration service this is new was
launched late in 2015 and it's a way to
replicate migrate or convert your
existing on-site databases into Amazon
Web Services and has a number of
features you can replicate your on-site
database
straight into Amazon or you can even get
it to convert to a different database
platform for you so if you have Oracle
on site and don't want to use it anymore
you can use DMS to convert your Oracle
database to Amazon or Ora or Microsoft
sequel server or anything like that so
it's a groundbreaking product that
Amazon is really pushing hard at the
moment then we have DynamoDB which is
Amazon's no SQL offering now we'll be
covering no SQL databases in the later
section so you don't have to worry about
that now but just remember DynamoDB
equals no SQL ElastiCache is a way of
caching your database services in the
cloud this is really cool if you have
users all running the same queries then
you can use ElastiCache to cache these
results in the ElastiCache service so
this means that the next time someone
runs the same query rather than pushing
the load all on to the database and
having to get the results back again the
users can just get the results directly
from ElastiCache and finally Amazon
redshift this is Amazon's data
warehousing service which again will
cover a much more detail in a later
lesson
but for now start remembering that
redshift is Amazon's data warehousing
service let's take a look at networking
and we'll start with Amazon V PC now V
PC stands for virtual private cloud and
it kind of works as a bridge between the
users existing IT infrastructure and
Amazon's Cloud and a V PC allows you to
create a safe secure private cloud
service that appears as if all your AWS
services are on your own network and you
can have numerous V pcs of in your
Amazon account so you could set up a
virtual private cloud for your
production environment and then one for
your development environment and VP C is
a big section and you need to know this
inside out and then we have a lesson on
V PC coming up where you'll get to
create your own virtual private clouds
and all the network configuration
associated with it route 53 is Amazon's
DNS and domain service so you can use it
to manage your domain DNS records and
you can also use it to manage your V PC
domain name services it's called route
53 because 53 is the port that DNS uses
and it's a play on words for route 66
which is a major highway in the US
Direct Connect is a way of connecting
into your Amazon Web Services
environment without having to use an
internet connection lease lines connect
directly from your data center or
network to Amazon Web Services I'm a
look at the analytics section now
we'll start with Amazon Elastic search
service this allows you to use the
popular open source search and analytics
engine elastic search as a managed
service in AWS elastic MapReduce allows
businesses and developers to process
large amounts of data using a Hadoop
framework and it's great for processes
like data mining and scientific
simulation again this is something that
you need to know at a high level so you
need to know what it is so elastic
MapReduce like Hadoop framework and data
mining Kinesis is a way of streaming
data to Amazon Web Services Kinesis can
ingest huge amounts of data very quickly
from things like mobile applications or
sensors Amazon machine learning you can
predict future behavior from existing
data now the best example of this is
that Amazon use this on their website so
when you are searching for a product on
amazon.com and you always see those
maybe you would like this option that's
machine learning in action quick site is
a very fast cloud powered business
intelligence service that makes it easy
for all employees to build
visualizations perform ad hoc analysis
and quickly get business insights from
their data and data pipeline this is
Amazon's ETL service so you can extract
transform and load data from elsewhere
in Amazon you can schedule when it
happens and you can also get alerts when
your ETL processes fail amazon offers a
number of enterprise applications to
help you reduce your IT infrastructure
the first of these is Amazon work Docs
which is an enterprise storage and
sharing service so you can share files
and documents where your colleagues
basically Amazon's answer to Dropbox or
Google Docs Amazon work mail is Amazon's
answer to Microsoft Exchange so you can
give everyone in your company the same
email system and calendar and finally
Amazon workspaces this is a managed
desktop computing service in the cloud
so you can create a variety of different
sized
Windows desktops that run in the cloud
and then your users can connect to them
so they don't actually need a very high
powered computer but they just need a PC
or a tablet with an internet connection
and then they can connect to the Windows
desktop in the cloud amazon offers a
number of mobile services to help you
with your app development the first of
these is Amazon Cognito which basically
saves your mobile user data in the cloud
and provides signup and sign-in access
to your mobile and web applications you
can use existing social identity
providers like Facebook or Twitter or
you can use your own solution to handle
it so in a nutshell Amazon Cognito
handles user management authentication
and sync across devices
mobile analytics is a way of tracking
and measuring what people are doing
inside your app so you can use this to
measure app usage and revenue generation
you can also track key trends like user
retention so you can see how well your
app is performing once you've released
it Amazon SNS which stands for simple
notification service allows you to send
mobile notifications emails and SMS
messages to your apps so you can
instantly deliver messages to your
applications using SNS some big brands
use this like Yelp periscope and even
tinder device farm allows you to test
your application on a bunch of different
iOS and Android devices simultaneously
this is really cool so once you've built
your app and you need to test it rather
than having to get your hands on one of
every type of device that is going to
run you can just upload it Amazon device
farm and they'll simultaneously test it
against all the devices that are out
there today
and finally AWS mobile hub this kind of
brings together all of the features
we've just talked about so that you
build test and monitor your mobile
applications so it easily lets you add
and configure features for your apps and
it handles user authentication data
storage and notifications Amazon has a
new service called Internet of Things or
IOT and this is a managed cloud platform
that lets connected devices for example
cars or light bulbs easily and securely
interact with cloud applications and
other devices so an example of this
would be how IOT could improve driver
safety with connected cars so for cars
driving along and the road is a bit
slippery it can upload this data or
information to Amazon IOT and IOT
processes the data based on rules and
interprets that the moisture levels are
high and it should send an alert to
nearby cars so it alerts nearby cars in
that area that moisture levels are high
and the drivers are alerted warning road
to slippery the data is also transferred
Amazon s3 so that the data can be used
for future analysis and it can be
analyzed with things like Amazon quick
site and machine learning so that in the
future predictions can be made so that
things will instantly be sent out when
certain events happen let's take a look
at some of the developer tools that
Amazon offer the first of these is
Amazon code commit and allows you to
create AWS hosted version control for
your code so it's basically Amazon's
version of github Amazon code deploy
allows you to get your code from code
commits repository and deploy it to your
ec2 instances and code pipeline is a
continuous delivery service for fast and
reliable application updates SoCo
pipeline build tests and deploys your
code every time there is a code change
based on the release process model that
you define AWS offers a suite of
management tools to help you look after
and monitor your AWS resources the first
of these is Amazon Cloud Watch and cloud
watch enables monitoring for ec2 and
other Amazon cloud services so you can
get alerts about AWS services when they
go wrong so you can set up alerts for
high CPU or high memory usage and cloud
watch can be linked with elastic load
balancer which we'll look at in the
latest lesson cloud formation is really
cool it allows you to set up a bunch of
connected AWS services in one go you
don't need to know how to do this you
just need to have a high level
understanding but it's a way of
basically saving templates of entire
environments you can press a button and
they just appear within minutes Amazon
Cloud Trail is Amazon's answer to
auditing so you can audit what users are
doing on your AWS resources config is a
way of tracking configuration management
changes so you can create rules to
ensure that your config isn't changing
or you can be alerted when the config is
changing
AWS opsworks is a configuration
management service that helps you
configure and manage operations using
chef so you can handle running your
application with things like auto
scaling so just need to remember that
ops work is chef AWS service catalog
Service Catalog allows organizations to
create and manage catalogs IT services
that are approved for use on AWS so you
can ensure compliance for your corporate
standards and you can help employees
quickly find and deploy approved IT
services from your AWS catalog and
lastly but not leastly trusted advisor
this is an automated service that
identifies areas where you're paying too
much for your AWS setup so it will look
for things like unused ec2 instances or
idle instances so this is a pretty cool
tool to run against your environment
especially if you have lots of servers
or instances and it will tell you what
you weigh you're wasting money in the
security and identity section
AWS offers AWS I am which stands for
identity and access management and this
is where you control access to your AWS
resources so you can set up users groups
manage their permissions keys passwords
and policies it's a huge area in the
exam and we'll cover it in more detail
in a later lesson
Amazon inspector is new and this is a
way to determine if you've set up your
instances in an insecure way so it's an
automated security assessment service
that helps improve the security and
compliance of your applications running
on AWS after it performs an assessment
it provides a detailed list of security
findings prioritized by severity Cloud
HSM which stands for hardware security
module is a service that helps you meet
corporate contractual and regulatory
compliance requirements for data
security with cloud HSM you can control
the encryption keys and cryptographic
operations performed by the HSM so what
this means is that Cloud HSM is a way to
secure your encryption keys in the cloud
in a very very secure environment AWS
directory service makes it easy to set
up and run Microsoft Active Directory in
the cloud or you can connect your AWS
resources with an existing on-premise
Microsoft Active Directory and this is
cool because it means rather than your
users having to log into the Amazon
resources using a different username and
password you can just link it with your
Active Directory so that people can just
log in with their the same password and
username they use to log into their
desktop AWS key management service or
kms is a managed service that makes it
easy for you to create and control the
encryption keys used to encrypt your
data like cloud HSM this uses hardware
security modules protect the security of
your keys and finally AWS WAF which
stands for Web Application Firewall so
you can use this service to block bad
requests to cloud front protected sites
or other way
sites that you're hosting on AWS and the
last section we'll look at is
application services the first of these
is API gateway which allows you to proxy
your application api's through this
service which is cool because it means
you can throttle bad client traffic or
you can test new versions and you can
present your methods more cleanly this
doesn't really feature in the exam so
you just need to know what it is app
stream lets you deliver your Windows
application to any device so you can put
a copy of a Windows application on the
Windows machine and then that people get
remote access to it cloud search is
Amazon's answer a full-text search so
you can quickly search through data
stored on s3 or in your RDS databases
and search it for particular instances
of words is kind of a full-text search
in the cloud elastic transcoder is a way
of transcoding media files so you can
use this service to change formats
compress video files and make your media
usable on all devices Amazon SES stands
for simple email service and you can
send one-off emails like marketing
emails or password resets or other
notifications and you can link it with
other AWS services like lambda Amazon s
Q S stands for simple key service and is
a hosted queue that increases workflow
between distributed components of
applications that perform different
tasks what this means is allows
developers to easily move data without
losing messages or requiring each
component to always be available it
doesn't have any logic it's just a place
to put things and take things out so
what that means is you can use Amazon
sqs to create a queue of work where each
message is a tasks that need to be
computed by a process one or many
computers can read these tasks from the
queue and perform them when they have
spare capacity and finally Amazon swf
simple workflow service this service
helps developers build run and scale
background jobs that have parallel or
sequential steps you can think of it as
a fully managed State right
and tasks coordinator now Amazon use
this in their warehouses so when you
order something on amazon.com it uses
SWF to process your order to ensure that
it is delivered on time and you get the
product you actually asked for so let's
review the key takeaways from this
lesson
Amazon Web Services is a secure cloud
services platform that offers
cloud-based infrastructure for compute
database storage content delivery and
other functionality to help businesses
scale and grow AWS is truly global it's
available in 190 countries through 12
geographic regions
a region is a geographic area isolated
from other Amazon regions to provide the
greatest possible fault tolerance an
availability zone is located within a
region and there are at least two
availability zones per region connected
via low latency links edge locations are
CDN content delivery networks and are
located all over the world in major
cities and are used to provide content
to end-users with low latency AWS has
cloud-based products to provide you with
compute resources like virtual servers
containers an auto scaling storage
object and block-based storage and
methods to transport your data to and
from AWS
databases RDS manage database services
plus database platforms for no SQL and
data warehousing networking AWS provides
VPC and route 53 to manage your networks
and DNS analytics AWS has a suite of
tools like Kinesis or machine learning
to help you speed up your data analytics
and data mining for enterprise
applications like work Docs or work
spaces which simplify your desktop and
file sharing mobile services AWS
provides a whole suite of applications
to assist your mobile application design
build and monitoring tools like mobile
hub or device farm will help you with
this Internet of Things AWS has a
product called IOT which collects data
from your internet-connected devices
there are developer tools which have
products to assist with source code
management and deployment like code
comment AWS provides management tools so
that you can manage your AWS environment
in the cloud tools like auditing
configuration management are provided
via cloud trail and cloud watch security
and identity I am allows you to control
your user access to AWS and inspector
check your resources for security
vulnerabilities and application
services there are tools to simplify and
automate your application workflow like
sqs or SWF
this concludes the AWS overview lesson
the next lesson is designing highly
available cost efficient fault tolerant
scalable systems
you